thank you
[Music]
all right I'm gonna tell you guys about
a dude named Moses All Right This Guy's
in his 40s and he was sick and tired of
being short
oh really yeah what's short he was five
five okay guys
what do you do about it
you got the surgery he spent 165
000 that he'd saved up uh working three
jobs basically walk over the course of
like three or four years and he got the
height lengthening surgery you guys know
how that works how tall is it now break
your legs
five five to five sit just look at this
picture how tall is he now that's him
and that's a different person five five
to five ten wow
that's
what I'm saying
dude I kill somebody to be five because
five minutes I think if he just had that
same confidence
yeah he's confident he wasn't trying to
fight five dude he's slouching yellow
too here his forehead looks different
like you didn't but did he like did he
but did he lengthen his arms to match no
no no no no it's all it's gonna look
like a T-Rex dude did say that like the
confidence of being told just caused an
overall Improvement in his whole wow
it's all in the head yeah what if he
walks like a baby giraffe though like I
mean he was walking [__] up for a
while so I bet dude recovery must be
crazy dude it's bad get that too there's
people with like super bad acne problems
right and then their confidence shrivels
and then they take like Accutane and
their face clears up and they feel like
yeah sometimes the outside affects the
inside sure but the problem with people
like this and Moses probably has the
same as issue is that like so I know
some [__] right as I'm sure you guys
do too just regular adult [__] and
sometimes like God damn it why is this
guy such a [__] [__] and you find
out they used to be fat
chip on their shoulder and I got this
[__] chip and it's like I can't see
where it comes we got a new [__] he's
gonna be an [__] do you think he's
gonna want me when I was short but now
I'm do you think he's gonna dunk on
shorter guys he should he should all
right like he's gonna be mean to like
the shorter dudes he just missed
everything
wait so wait how does physiologically
speaking how does this happen all right
so listen to this it's kind of like you
guys had braces anybody yeah yeah you
know when you get your braces tightened
and it's like you got to go every once
in a while it didn't make me any taller
yes so that's sort of similar to this
you gotta chop the tibia and then you
put a device in it right oh my God yeah
you go in to get it cranked and it
splits your bone up
the area that breaks fills up with more
calcium and Bone and then you go back
you do it again so he got five inches
from that over time over time he earned
that bro you gotta do it for a long time
how long has he been doing this are you
slowly getting taller he's been doing it
I think like like years like a couple
years maybe yeah yeah so you slowly get
taller and taller and eventually he got
five inches out of it and you could kind
of go to six but it's like it gets risky
the more you go like Teeth Whitening oh
my God yes and you don't have any teeth
left yeah yeah this is the human mod era
bro yeah
like crazy technology that's coming out
that could just change people's faces
which is oh yeah dude now you can get
taller like that sounds kind of tight
like I'm gonna get some pamphlets I
think
I'm not gonna do it but I'll look into
read about it yeah would you do it
though if it was like a quick and easy
thing nah dude not even what if there
was no side effects because what I'm
worried about is like you do this and
you can't run and Sprint anymore he
can't run in Spring yeah he can't play
sports dude it'll be a little bit but
you can eventually get back to them
that's what that says he was before he's
the third guy to do this
oh how do they know you wait for the
test run you're gonna be like did you
have your legs lengthened you're
supposed to be higher bro you're gonna
end up on a commercial are you six
inches taller than you were born yeah
absolutely I saw this other one where
this guy went from like five four to
five seven or something yeah and I was
like that's not even that different bro
you're not you're not at that threshold
like I think five five okay if you're
gonna be five five and you want the
lengthening then you could be like a
legit tall person I think 510 is the
threshold yeah bro five seven dude five
five seven because five no one ever
calls five nine it's the same [__] you
know I mean like five seven five they
find the same [__] doesn't [__]
matter you need to break the 510 then
you're like oh [__] I got six feet yeah
yeah yeah yeah until you like walking
there's ranges if you walk up something
you're like oh wait this guy's just 5
10. oh yeah it's far away you know why
because you're six foot passing when you
have boots on yeah yeah yeah
like five six to five nine who cares
right nobody cares you're about your
height really but 510 that's 5 10 and
above yeah you're six foot passes
he was wearing the slope shoe still so
he still needs a little couple inches
you got a Skechers
showed the video after he walked away
from the picture
[Laughter]
he seems like kind of like just like a
sad soul like he's talking about how
much like he he had such low confidence
and then he even tried taking hype pills
which he didn't know was a scam yeah
well he was taking him forever but guys
ever
um obsessed over like a body part or
like you know like a like a something
that feels like a deficiency in you like
oh like something you're unsatisfied
with yeah dude I always wanted to be
taller I didn't know hype was an
attraction thing until recently oh until
really blown until girls tender profiles
that don't hit me up unless you're yeah
5 10 or up because I was around a lot of
Latina and Asians so a lot and then like
you know they're small so like we're
smart for me it wasn't an attraction
thing it was more for sports
like athletes are just taller like when
you're taller you're just better at
sports athletically so I was like
because even like sprinters average
sprinters like 5 10 5 11 if you want to
play basketball you gotta be like six
feet just every sport yeah
like all the best athletes they're
generally like six feet around there
what was your ideal and when did it
start uh you're like in high school or
like yeah I think probably in high
school where like when I first started
wrestling I was like man it'd be nice to
not arrest a lot of girl weight
equipped by wrestle that like a man wait
or something well you're in 90 pounds I
know exactly damn not even triple Digis
dude and then and then I went to
um and then I went to what is it called
uh I went to another school and then I
ended up playing basketball there oh
yeah and tough yeah when you play it and
then so that's yeah
nothing here's Daisy
that last year it was a state champion
team but they're all seniors so they all
bounced so I remember that when we when
we all tried out the guy that was 6'4
was from the team last year and then uh
the coach that was like you're playing
Center this year oh he goes what the
[__] he's like what the [__] because
dude I was a [__] small foreign
so like now it's like he's all mad at
you guys yeah everyone's like a five
nine five ten team and everyone's just
short across the board yeah and then I
was like low Center gravity it was your
height Journey like groin what was your
growth spur like what I have my gross
bro early yeah it was always one of the
taller kids in my class and then like I
feel like a middle school it kind of
levels out you know I mean everyone's
kind of gets taller and then I hit like
after my last growth spurt in high
school like I was always one of the
taller kids I had like hit it fast but I
wasn't always like the biggest kid and I
was always skinny as [__] and then I
started playing I mean I always played
football then the high school started
playing football I remember my first
like real weightlifting situation in off
season like I'm thinking I'm strong I
was always working out but never like
football weightlifting and these two
older dudes who were like friends of
mine like all right yeah Capcom hit this
it was 135 45 on each side I didn't ever
hit 135 before but it seemed within my
range and they let it off the [__]
rack and cool
on top of me and like they were just
like laughing so hard and I was like
never again
yeah because that Dave [__] me up and
then I was like I got it and also like
they just give positions to the bigger
dudes yeah without even seeing their
skill first and like I needed to compete
so I had to get big so you obsessed over
your entire body every single muscle you
see someone who it might even be
something that correlates like someone
faster might have this one muscle look I
need that I need that because he has it
and he's fast yeah
um I don't know if a football they did
this but in basketball like tryouts is
kind of like you just have a bunch of
people right and then it's just like
okay just just throw five on five on
each other and they watch how the game
Dynamic goes and then okay you're out
you're in yeah um what is that is that
called Sprint manager what is that
called yeah I guess it's just like a
scrimmage area so like in that when you
start seeing body shapes and sizes and
you're just like
okay I can see like this guy is
literally two times faster than me yeah
this guy oh [__] there's an interception
I'm going for it I go like this and then
the guy behind me is like yeah I'm like
oh no you know you just start seeing
like body shapes and sizes and what they
can do and you go back and look at the
mirrors
[Laughter]
we were like all training as a fight
team and there's this one dude he's
still a good friend he kind of looked
like he was like Middle Eastern but he
was like half black and half white or
something like that but he looked like
he was like Armenian which was like a
weird thing but this dude played college
football his whole like you know he he's
a career athlete amazing athlete and
then we started like sparring and I was
like oh this is a different caliber of
individual as far as like how good he
was how fast he was how explosive he was
and at the time I I was like a buck
30 right like I've never strength
trained in my life and I was like
sparring with this dude and I was like
oh this guy is beating the absolute [__]
out of me and you guys have the same
skills same success
exactly and I just was like what the
[__] I could not figure it out you know
but like the more you play when others
do sports with all these different body
types the more you realize like oh [__]
like strength has so much
arm length like limb length the earlier
the body of dysmorphia starts the better
athlete you will be boom it's too late
see that's what happened to me I think I
was too body positive in my whole life
and then I realized I was like oh my god
I've been wrong this whole time I was
like you guys didn't tell me to lift
weights like this is terrible because
the only body dysmorphia I had was about
not being circumcised
[Laughter]
wait you were for being uncircumcised or
being circumcised no because I saw I
I'll uh we would go pee together in
elementary school and I was like how
come mine doesn't look like yours and
then and then I just thought like I had
an Asian dick because all the other
Asian kids were uncircumcised too until
these other kids Dale's like how come
it's like this and in my dad's
uncircumcised too and I'm like how come
mines look like an elephant truck and
then throughout life I was like oh man
you seen a lot of dick yeah you're
supposed to a lot of dick at an early
age yeah he says he had to go pee with
your friends that was like a fun thing
to do I don't know I don't look at the
when you go pee with them you don't look
at the dick scan I don't pee with them
kids like pants to the ankles lift my
shirt up we all did that and then I
don't know in kindergarten it was just a
thing where I was like I gotta go to the
bathroom and then we're like I gotta go
too and then we all go to one stall yeah
and pee in the same toilet we thought
that was so funny
it's like a selfie over
I'm never a toilet blue coffee but like
it was a fun adventure I don't know why
it was just something funny so you never
asked anybody else like how come yours
is I asked my parents oh yeah they're
like you're not circumcised and I was
like what's that and they're like well
we don't do that in Japan so it just I
don't see the reason why to do it and
then so most people in Japan are not I
would just yeah think about it's like
Europe like they don't do it there too
so then later I would keep thinking
about it and I'm like am I like in
fourth fifth grade now and I'm all like
[__] am I if I get married like is it
like if everyone in America does it like
it's gonna be so weird yeah so my my
body dysmorphia was on my dick only I
didn't care about my height just by
circumstance just my dick it was funny I
was afraid at a young age that like I
was gonna die a virgin
like fifth grade fourth really I think
I'm like damn dude like what if because
you know what it was I think it's a lot
of religion like I grew up in the church
talk about the world ending all the time
yeah it's almost like the end of the
world end of the world
that's coming could be today
right now so it's like you're like damn
what if that [__] ends I'm a [__]
virgin so every day I was like what if
it's today what is the [__] meteor
hits today and I'm [__] like as early
as like fifth grade
that is true they always tell you that
yeah what religion was it uh it was
Lutheran yeah
foreign